So using all of the information we had about
Kate's family, we should know that fourth answer represents
the pedigree of lactose intolerance for Kate's family. Remember,
Kate is lactose intolerant, but not her brother. So when
we look at these five options down here, we
should be looking for a pedigree that has a
female symbol or circle that's shaded in. Meaning that
they are affected by lactose intolerance. This pedigree here has
an unaffected female and an affected brother. So that's
not what we want. All of the other four pedigrees
have an affected female with an unaffected brother. So
now we go up a generation and look at the
parents. We see that, based on information, neither of
Kate's parents are lactose intolerant. Well if neither of her
parents are lactose intolerant, they shouldn't be shaded at
all. This one has a shaded parent, so that can't
be right. And this one has a shaded parent,
so an affected parent, so that can't be right. Only
these two pedigrees show parents that are unaffected, unshaded.
And the last piece of information is that the maternal
grandfather and paternal aunt are intolerant like Kate. So
we need to find where the mother's grandfather is affected
which is right here. Over here it's the paternal
grandfather, right? There's the grandfather but it's on the father's
side based on the square male symbol.
Although the paternal aunt is preserved in both
of these pedigrees or you see the
sister of the father here, the unaffected father,
the sister is affected. But because this
is the paternal grandfather and not the maternal
grandfather, we know that's not right and
that leaves us with this one pedigree here.